hey everybody what's going on blah here
i'm here in the uh abe lincoln museum in
springfield illinois for uh behind the
scenes of the lincoln remote
what
[Music]
the whole book is just
one of the coolest parts of this museum
is that they have an exact replica of
abe lincoln's cabin i'm guessing where
he grew up each one of these trees is an
exact replica of a real tree down in the
woods wherever this actual cabin was
seems like a terrible waste of money
[Music]
so we are at the capitol building i have
no idea what happened here because i
didn't pay attention to school let's go
inside
[Music]
no i like my wife keeps me from talking
about like it too much is she sort of
marital to your linkedin no i didn't
think so
[Music]
one kind of strange poster caught my eye
here at the old state house uh lincoln
your mind eye awakes that's when he was
running on the uh
platform
[Music]
maybe
and then you start
fighting people that would be fantastic
i'll tell you a little bit about them
they're all the 16th president of the
united states
they're all
prone to depression
and they're all named abraham lincoln
this is kind of a history channel
version of the bachelorette
that's what i think we're looking at
right now
[Music]
one of my favorite things here that
we've found is this great statue of
stephen a douglas one of lincoln's
political rivals out throughout his
entire life and um he's also known for
having a small bladder which is why he's
uh kind of
[Music]
no good shake your head
she's over there
that's good that's good that's good
that'll be good okay good it's been a
fascinating experience i thought i knew
a lot about abraham lincoln but
apparently
what i didn't know is there are four of
[Music]
and that's them